in this talk I would like to give you an
idea of the scope and of the character
of this research obviously I will not
even try to present a complete survey
instead I will focus on a few research
efforts picking ones closer to my heart
closer to this lab also closer to the
present and perhaps to the future for
our present purposes we could say that
the present starts with a famous memo by
Bill Gates in this memo from early 2002
very soon after this lab was founded
Bill Gates said trustworthy computing as
a top priority for the company although
trustworthy computing has several
important aspects security certainly
received a huge amount of the attention
around the time of Bill Gates memo one
school of thought on security said that
by and large we know plenty of
mechanisms that could improve security
if they were applied but that what was
lacking was the wheel to deploy these
mechanisms there is perhaps some truth
to this point of view however it ignores
the fact that computers and computing
systems are always changing and that
attacks are changing to the defense's
must evolve as well in addition as the
stakes get larger we may want higher
confidence higher assurance about the
defenses old or new and we may also be
prepared to make different trade-offs
between security compatibility and
performance with this in mind when way
of organizing our thinking about the
defenses is in terms of butter lamp sins
golden rule or gold standard butter who
is now in the New England lab wrote that
there are three basic mechanisms for
implementing security and that together
they form the gold standard for security
authenticating principles consist in
answering the question
who's said that or who's getting that
information authorizing access consists
in answering the question who can do
which operations on this object and
finally we also need other thing which
concerns examining the decisions of the
guard in order to figure out what
happened and why these three mechanisms
should be understood as pieces of the
implementation of security policies
within models of security today however
I will not get into details on security
models and security policies but I will
tell you about some research work on
each of these three mechanisms starting
with authentication one important way of
performing authentication is with
cryptographic protocols in this approach
users computers and other principles can
be associated with secret secret
cryptographic keys which are used for
identifying them so the story goes we
may for example have two users Alice and
Bob here who know the same key K and
then Allie's may use this key for
signing or for encrypting a message that
she may send to Bob on a public channel
such as the Internet despite the
presence of Eve here and other attackers
a signature can ensure the authenticity
of the message that Bob receives an
encryption its secrecy in general
cryptographic protocols are not so
simple of course there is a long-lost
race history of cryptographic protocols
full of clever ideas but also full of
subtleties and all vulnerabilities
because of these vulnerabilities and
subtleties there has been a lot of
interest in developing rigorous methods
for the designer analysis of
cryptographic protocols for example the
protocols may be expressed in the
programming language called the process
calculus then verified using theorem
provers and other such tools in a
process calculus Alice might simply be
defined as a program that sends a
message m
protected under the key K on the channel
Internet similarly Bob might for example
be defined as a program that receives a
message X on internet then checks that
the message is protected under k and
then proceeds and their combination is a
system in which they run in peril this
vertical bar here is the parallel
composition operator using a fresh
private he came within Microsoft we have
developed this idea and apply it to a
number of protocols some part of product
efforts some coming from elsewhere it is
only quite recently that this line of
research has reached the maturity of
allowing us to reason about some actual
implementations of important protocols
written in languages such as c or f
sharp the epicenter of this progress in
the last few years has been somewhere
between the cambridge lab and the MSR in
we are joint center in france for
instance they have written a reference
implementation of TLS which is the IETF
standard for SSL enough sharp then
compiled it to a process calculus and
then analyzed it automatically using
sort of tier improving tool of course
not all authentication relies on
cryptography sometimes for instance we
employ usernames and passwords for
identifying users and the like sometimes
even weaker indicators can help for
tracking users and computers these may
include for example IP addresses and
also browser cookies and other
identifiers for browsers the tracking
may obviously raise privacy concerns and
it is not perfect but it can be quite
helpful particularly when combined with
other techniques we rely on some of
these identifiers in some of our work on
auditing to which I will return in a few
minutes no matter how authentication is
done its result is often the input to an
authorization decision authorization
happens at many levels in systems here
we'll tell you about the family of
projects focused on low-level attacks
and low-level defenses basically we
consider situations in which various
pieces of code not all equally trusted
share an address space such situations
arise commonly in operating systems
browsers and in other settings and then
we are interested in questions such as
is it ok to write to this address in
memory or is control allowed to jump to
this instruction this latter kind of
question about the flow of control is
essential for authorization
fundamentally we must enforce that the
flow of control conforms to the expected
control flow graph or in other words
that we have control flow integrity if
we cannot restrict the control flow of
programs then we cannot guarantee that
they do not circumvent the checks on
which security depends in fact many
attacks over the years rely on buffer
overflows and other low-level
vulnerabilities precisely in order to
subvert control flow languages such as
Java and C sharp can help in those
situations these high-level languages
and their type systems can help enforce
fundamental properties of control flow
and of memory accesses properties that
are not generally true for arbitrary
binaries for example with these
languages we can often guarantee that
when a function of one calls another
function of two and control is
transferred from f1 to f2 the control
flow goes to the beginning of F two's
body and not to the middle if the
beginning of the body contains a check
that aims to guarantee that it's safe to
perform a certain operation and the
middle contains the operation itself
then this guarantee implies that the
check cannot be circumvented this use of
languages for security was a very
frequent theme in work a few years ago
and it remains quite important however
there's still a huge amount of code that
is not written in those languages
moreover despite a lot of progress in
fixing buffer overflows and other
low-level vulnerabilities and also a lot
of progress and tools like the tools
sage from redmond for finding
vulnerabilities we have to be mindful of
the possibility that we may not be able
to find and to eliminate all buffer
overflows or all other mistakes in code
we can look at this as a setback but we
can also look at this as a sort of
opportunity in fact there are several
recent research efforts that start from
the somewhat depressing premise that
vulnerabilities existing software and
that they may always exist and then look
for good next moves in this direction
one idea which we explored in this lab
in collaboration with colleagues in
Redmond is to add instrumentation to
binaries by rewriting the binaries an
attractive variant which has been
explored in the MSR lab in Cambridge is
to rely on compilers for inserting
instrumentation in either case the
instrumentation will appear just before
control flow transfers and at runtime it
will check that the targets of this
transfers are allowed by a given policy
again several options are open for how
this is done one possibility is to place
a distinct label at the allowed targets
of control flow transfers and then to
check for the presence of the label just
before each transfer for example we
could insert the label 12345678 at the
start of the check and the different
label 2 4 6 8 35
7-9 just before the operation and at
every place where there is a computed
jump say a call instruction we could
insert the verification that ensures
that the target address of the jump
contains the expected label for example
one two three four five six seven eight
so that in particular the jump does not
go directly to the operation if he
should instead go to the check another
possibility as an alternative to this
use of labels inserted into the code is
to set up and to manage an auxiliary
data structure that encodes the allowed
transfers of control whichever of these
possibilities is adopting an
implementation one very attractive
properties that we can actually prove
formally rigorously that control flow
has the expected properties that it
follows the expected control flow graph
this is in contrast with a lot of work
unuseful but in perfect mitigations like
stuck gardens and practical forms of
layout randomization which attackers
typically find hard to circumvent or
break but which sometimes don't cut it
so we're working on indication and
authorization but authentication and
authorization don't always do very much
or don't work as expected so we also
need auditing this is particularly true
for many services where authentication
and authorization are quite modest or
quite rudimentary an example of this is
a free email service in such a service
it is generally very easy for anyone or
almost anyone to set up an account and
to begin to send and to receive email it
is also fairly common for user passwords
to be stolen or to be guests by
attackers so one challenge then is to
distinguish legitimate users from
spammers and from other attackers
another challenge is to detect when
accounts have been compromised and to
disable those accounts or to try to
recover them
and this can be seen as to auditing
tasks for instance in one very recent
project an ongoing project we use social
graphs for distinguishing likely good
accounts from bad accounts in hotmail
suppose that we make a graph were the
nodes represent users of the email
service and we place an edge between two
nodes if the corresponding accounts
communicate sufficiently in both
directions for a suitable value of
sufficiently so for example there may be
an edge between Alice and Bob because
they send lots and lots of female to
each other but there would not be an
edge between the attacker and Bob
because although the attacker might send
a lot of spam to Bob Bob might not reply
very often it turns out that in this
social graph there's a huge connected
component in which most accounts are
good so we may use membership in this
huge connected component as a very
useful signal in distinguishing good
accounts from bad accounts of course
there are many variants on these ideas
overall it looks like a very intriguing
and a very promising approach
another facet of our work on auditing
concerns web search much like in the
case of free email services anyone or
almost anyone can do web searches and
almost anyone can set up web pages that
may get indexed and those web pages may
of course contain deceptive contents or
malware so in collaboration with beings
and with colleagues from academia we
have been exploring the ways in which
attackers try to abuse search engines
one facet of this work is a system
called search audit we look at the Bing
query stream we know a priori about a
few malicious queries and about some
malicious source IP addresses then we
generalize and we try to find more
queries and more source IP addresses for
instance we can construct regular
expressions that contain all the known
malicious queries and then we see what
we discover in particular it turns out
that one very large group of malicious
queries is looking for strings that will
identify vulnerable web servers for
instance to posit an attacker knows that
the software package called data life
engine contains a vulnerable nura
bilities it may search for the string
power bi data life engine and then try
to compromise the servers with web pages
that contain the string we found that
attackers employ searches in this and
several other ingenious ways search
engines are a powerful tool are not only
for legitimate good users but examining
the anonymize search logs we can often
understand the attacks under trends and
we can often block them another facet of
our work on auditing for web search is a
system called the sale or D SEO where
SEO stands for search engine
optimization of course the system helps
us look for web pages put up by
attackers on compromised servers for
instance an attacker may create a page
that gets improving the results for some
popular searches
and when a user goes to the page it
generates a pop-up that pretends to be
an antivirus program and tries to scare
the user into doing something foolish
and dangerous it turns out however that
those bad web pages have some properties
and some regularities that can help us
identify them for instance their URLs
are generated automatically by attackers
so they often have common structures and
patterns then we can use for recognizing
them in these projects and auditing and
in many other projects in ms are one
silly characteristic is that we will
rely on huge amount of data such as the
anonymized logs of hotmail and bing and
on large-scale infrastructures for data
analysis like dried laying that me hi
would you mentioned earlier today in
addition we have fairly rich
interactions with product groups not all
interactions are alike but generally the
interactions are rather easy and
productive a third characteristic of the
research is that were generally playing
defense like researchers in academia and
in many security companies we spend some
of our time looking forward voller
abilities for attacks against Microsoft
products and against other systems but
generally that is not the main focus of
our work as we're speaking of defense I
will leave you with this drawing of a
guard as a final image during the French
Revolution the designers on the most a
new york designed a set of playing cards
of which i have a reproduction here in
which the Kings the queens and the jacks
disappeared were eliminated and they
will replace with more revolutionary
images to do with freedom equality and
so on liberté egalité a and there were
cars with images for other good things
like courage enlightenment and
what else enterprise which I have here
I'm curiously the set included also a
card for security the car that you see
on the screen I securus Lee because one
does not usually think of security as an
exciting revolutionary concept but
certainly some degree of security is
crucial for many of the revolutionary
applications of computing thank you